The project is faculty's
lived experiences
teaching online
courses, whether that's
a more traditional extension
school, credit-bearing course,
or a Massive Open
Online Course and what
they learn from
the experience, how
it applies to their residential
teaching and their research.
We've both worked with faculty
for going on five years
now at HarvardX.
And there's a really
great developed parts
of the organization
and across university
that study student
experiences taking courses.
But there's really-- it feels
like a dearth of research
around faculty's experience
teaching courses.
And we had both,
anecdotally, in the courses
that we have managed, heard
a lot of overlapping things,
both positive and
also things faculty
wished they had known
when they had started.
And we wanted to
really formalize
that in using the Spark
grant in a study design,
so that we could pull out
these faculty experiences
to share with
prospective faculty who
are thinking about
developing online courses.
And also, staff and
course developers
who are working with faculty
to improve their experiences.
Some preliminary things we
found are that across the board,
I think, faculty were
surprised at how long it takes
to create an online course.
It's quite different than
creating a residential course.
A lot of faculty
transformed the way
they teach in their
residential course based
on their experiences
teaching online.
They tend to teach
more interactively
after teaching online.
And also, a few them
were able to work
on projects that were more
interdisciplinary that they
otherwise wouldn't have a chance
to do in a residential setting
and to collaborate with faculty
that they wouldn't otherwise
collaborate with.
And some of them altered
their research interests
and gave them a more
global perspective
on those who are doing
Massive Open Online Courses.
In some ways, we're still
in the preliminary stages,
in the sense that the
Spark grant helped
us get to the stage where
we are now to start actually
using our time to
go through what
has been coded to then determine
a quasi-list of best practices.
And also, to turn around and
present back to the university
is really important
for what we're doing.
So while the grant
is up, it doesn't
mean that the work that
we're doing is done.
In some sense, it's pushed
us to the next stage.
I think putting together
a timeline early on
is really important.
Obviously, you want to
leave yourself flexibility
as you explore and
develop new ideas.
But in general,
it's a grant, which
has a specific amount
of time around it.
And you really want to know
what your deliverable is
at the end Holt is very
generous with giving us
the freedom of
establishing our own goals.
But you still want to
set those goals early on.
You don't want it to just
be an exploratory space.
You really want to know
what you're going into
and set internal
deliverables to make
sure you've reached that goal.
The most valuable part of this
grant was having a great coach.
Rebecca was amazing.
And just really having a
sounding board and someone
to cheer lead us along and
think through the process
was so helpful.
I think the process would
not have been the same at all
without her.
I think she was,
in some ways, even
more valuable than the money.
Yeah.
I'd totally sign off for that.
Rebecca, that's our coach, was
very supportive and helpful
and I think
emblematic, generally,
of what Holt represented
for us, which was a support
structure when we needed it.
No one was poking around,
asking us what were doing,
but if we needed
help or support,
we knew that it was there,
which was really, really
nice with this sort of grant.